[Music]
okay so thanks for everyone for coming
up we're going to start with some games
mitad from people on youtube I don't
know if you guys have like seen the
YouTube channel but we're starting a new
series where people submit the games to
one of the emails and if you could like
link the email somewhere in this frame
gauger okay yeah just submit it to this
email and it will get to whoever the
resident GM is and then if it's decent
quality game we could go over it so I'm
going to start with some games which I
found pretty interesting I don't know if
we'll get through all of them but
hopefully we'll get through most of them
so first game Justin C okay put in
training mode and most people like write
a little notes to Jonathan for some
reason I don't know why Jonathan is
always the point of contact but the same
was submitted I I want to hurt myself
connecting this name here oh the Gucci
and it was actually from a tournament
that I played it was the US Amateur team
tournament in Chicago a few months ago
and he lost I'll hire a player and I
thought it was a really interactive game
at certain points so I'll take you
through and then just explain like those
moments so it was a ready opening I know
if anyone plays this anyone play this
opening is white kind of English ready
after East six white usually has two
main moves either g3 or d4
whatwhy plays in this game is sort of
unusual played III and III is a little
bit committal because you're basically
committing your Bishop to develop to e2
or maybe
gg3 and it's not that friendly to this
bishop and usually if you're going to
play e3 then later you'll have to play
III and Bishop b2 so if you're playing
this is why I would usually recommend
this playing g3 or d4 ever
those are the more challenging lines but
okay III was played five six Knight c3
and want to zoom forward to the middle
game nothing too eventful happened one
thing I should note though is that if
like plays in early g3 and Bishop g2
then b6 is sometimes harder to play if
the bishop already develops to the long
diagonal but this case black develops
without too many problems and they reach
this position where this was the first
interesting moment white played d3 which
is a a little bit passive and I don't
know if I understand the purpose behind
this move
I think if light wants to go some for
some more active play a better option
would be to take and one of the points
behind taking is that so you take d5
then I can play d4 an idea is to open up
the position and eventually trade these
pawns and if black ever takes on d4 does
anyone know what the best piece to take
back with would be three options for
white you can take with the the Queen
the pawn or the next
okay we're going to take a poll who says
take this upon one person who says take
with the Queen a couple people
let's take with a knight most people
yeah I would take with the night I'll go
through if you take with the Queen then
black and develop with tempo xu6 you
lose a little bit of time you take with
the Knights because you leave flack with
ice to the D pawn and this is a very
common goal in a lot of these openings
is to leave your opponent with a
isolated pawn that's blockaded by a
knight it would be maybe a slight
mistake to take with the pond because
then both sides have a nice type off and
white can't really argue that there's
much advantage here so a slightly better
way of playing but what I noticed in
this game like kind of played passively
and then eventually black did like very
well to take advantage of white passive
play so will go forward
nice e6 Queen e2 now exactly as rook c8
here a better move would be d4 just more
aggressive point being that if take
black to take that this upon and it's
just really nice space advantage for for
black and it flex play something like 94
then black can take take and be 5 and
this is just an incredible positioning
for black especially right out the
opening to have more space in the center
actually defended passed pawn on d4 and
I would very much prefer black here so
what happened the game black played a
little slower play rook c8 rook c-137
take take an Audi for so White's kind of
going for the idea which I said before
but he lost a little bit of time playing
d3 and then V 4 and because of that
black is able to get a bit more activity
rook F D 8 and here think white made a
slight mistake play Knight a 4 right
away and my general recommendation
whenever you're kind of leaving the
opening and entering the middle game you
want to make sure that
your pieces are optimized before you
carry through with some plan and in this
case White's developed for the most part
but there's still the rook to improve so
I think the the most intuitive and most
natural move here would be rip to you on
just make sure all of your pieces are in
good position before you start going for
something and this is a theme that we'll
see in the other games to where
sometimes if you go for a plan too early
then your pieces won't be on the best
wear is to better equip yourself for
what's going to happen so yeah Brooke d1
and just one interesting thing about
this position neither player would like
their queen on the C or D file because
the C and D file are occupied by both
rooks so common move for black here
would be Queen b8 just to get off the
x-ray vision and interestingly enough a
move for white would be queen d3 - maybe
maneuver to be one or maybe more
aggressively maneuver task 5 I thought
was interesting whenever the rooks are
lined up like this and files might open
up later you don't want your Queen on
the same file as your opponent's rook so
okay what happened the game 9a for zoom
forward 90 for Queen c2 Queen B a very
good move and now we see there's some
issues for whites so take take Knight c3
take tick and now this is a really key
position and I was really really
impressed by what black did for the next
several moves to pretty much gain a huge
decisive advantage so I'll let you guys
think for a little bit in this position
and then we can discuss but if anyone
has any ideas for black feel free shout
it out and we can discuss you could be
four it's exactly what lasted d4 is by
far the strongest move
not before like before the threats but
you could allow light just to simplify
what they should take before but d4
essentially gives white the most
problems and the goal for black is to
open up the position because the pieces
are better placed for black and usually
when your pieces are better placed the
opening of the position favors favors
that side so a black wants to do
perhaps exchange these pawns and then
the C file would be open and there would
be more tactical possibilities so from
this point forward we'll see that black
does a really good job at keeping the
initiative pretty much every single move
for the next I think four or five moves
is a very direct effect so the first
threat of course blacks attacking bishop
i plays Bishop to b2 black continues
initiative night before forcing the
Queen's retreats Queen b1 black
continues initiative with a very nice
move here I'll let you guys try and
think to find it b3 very good and notice
black is pretty much improving every
single move like d4 Knight d4 d3 and
white is kind of worsening the pieces
every single move there should be two
Queen e1 now Bishop to d1 and it
continues like this
b2 kind of a strange position to have a
pond on the second rank in the middle
game but what this is doing is basically
setting up some some tactics because
it's forcing the rope to move rook
doesn't have too many options in the
game
rook c4 is played and now what should
stick out immediately is now the refer
line and move should be screaming itself
Bishop to a6 so what's going to happen
from here is black black one material
and then ended up winning the game
without too much more efforts I'll show
you the final few moves
what white tried to do was kind of try
and take over the initiative because so
far it's been black dictating all the
play and white
tried to make some counter threats but
what ended up happening black just ifuse
everything and one pretty easily so why
played rook g4 and what this does it
saves the rook on c4 and attacks g7 and
black dog has to be a little bit careful
because there's pieces aimed towards the
Kings side and you don't want to get
careless here and play a move like they
should take f1 and run into rotate q7 so
I like the way black played f6 basically
just going the bishop on on b2 and this
was very common like positioning in
chess whenever it is a bishop together
if it's staring at a pawn chain then
Bishop is an aster on Queenie for what I
was trying to be resourceful attacking
bishop 97 black simply plays Queen b6
and notice earlier the tactic was a
skewer but it's it's still a trap but
the rook on f1 is just trapped so I
can't really get out of it that easily
rook take g7 was played and this was I
guess just desperation white didn't know
what to do so just tried something
desperate
but at this point black is much much
better several kg 7 rook sorry h4 maybe
yeah maybe that's a better try just hope
for something yeah probably a rook each
for all black wants to do is just simply
the fandom in win material it's actually
a really cool move here OS 5 actually I
didn't see f5 ah looks like it attacks
the Queen in the routine I didn't before
people who follow maybe hobbies a
weekend event right before really maybe
before we need for yeah five is just
kind of a simple tactic you know you
just and age seven and you attack the
Queen and the rook move I was looking at
there should be three it's kind of cool
yeah defending the H ponder x-ray vision
so I think either of these moves
maybe we combine our ideas it's like
flexpay's queen g4 then you play
oh you don't play outside cuz it's man
on g7 but at least at least now the
threaded statues yeah so yeah I thought
this was kind of it started off kind of
a slow game both sides were playing
slowly and then white just made a few
mistakes like played two passively
didn't play d4 quickly enough didn't uh
didn't develop this rook on f1 which
turned out to be kind of the cause of
loss for whites so any questions
regarding this game other games maybe a
bit lower quality where we'll try and
focus more on specific moments that can
be instructive I will say that there are
some games that were submitted very low
quality we might look at those briefly
just to kind of laugh and and try and
learn the lesson or two but let's move
on
so okay next game I went through these
games earlier and I think there were
some things to learn about this game
this was from I don't think he said the
name but this was dynamic chess I
believe this was an online game
five-minute time control and this was
actually a really cool game I was pretty
impressed with this game because the
player was I mean decent player but he
he kind of played pretty brilliantly so
and I think we'll zoom through the
opening quickly I'll just point out one
or two quick things but later in the
game there's like a brilliant
accommodation so it was a London for
whites King's Indian for black anyone
played the London here I know you do
I play London - sometimes anyone played
King's Indian
yeah again yeah okay so it started off
very normally but out of nowhere white
played a very strange move h4 and you'll
see this from a lot of openings where
maybe more middle games where white
wants to attack against a fee incredible
structure and ideas to play h5 open
h-file and attack in this position h4
isn't really good it's premature and
it's also kind of applied so the same
lesson we talked about earlier that you
want to develop all your pieces before
you start doing something and in this
case white is not fully developed at all
so it's better for white to like play I
don't know
c4 and 93 maybe Bishop e2 Bishop e3 and
then later if if it makes sense maybe
maybe go for a King side attack with h4
but h4 right away first problem is
White's not threatening h5 because just
might take h5 second problem is it
weakens the g4 square and black can very
safely put a bishop on g4 and not have
to worry about h3 and this is a very
common problem whenever you play moves
like h4 or a 4 you're usually weakening
the g4 d4 square so we'll go forward
black eventually puts the bishop on g4
on them bishops get traded and if we
know this black is pretty much
completely done with developing modern
pieces and castling and white still has
work to do in development c4 now e5 and
this is a very common type of principle
in chess
when you're finished development and
your opponent is max you want to open up
the position as quickly as possible and
that's very important that you try to do
it quickly because if you give your
opponent few free moves sometimes it
won't be as strong so in this case I
really like this movie 5 it has a few
threats to it basically forces like to
take take Bishop c5 and again we see a
nice example of the initiative I'll give
you guys a few moments to think in this
position black
to move and you want to look for threats
but you also want to look for kind of
weaknesses and targets so rook e8 uh why
oh because you're you have some x-ray
vision actually rook e8 you're thinking
about Knight d4 right that's interesting
I was not his father back that is an
idea I think it's a little slow 94 is a
lot quicker and night before I think is
a strongest move because you have
basically two immediate threats yeah and
they're very direct to Knight see to
fork England material 93 also take a
late likes castling rights and this is
hard to stop for for lights because if
you castle your rook still gets trapped
Castle might see two so the problem not
only is a fork but it's a trap
so why it was somewhat resourceful hero
I played Knight to e4 going for a
counter play defends mighty to a lot
continue naturally nice 83 and night to
d3 King f1 and I want to give you guys
another chance to think in this position
I was really impressed with the move
that black played so if anyone has any
ideas feel free
yes yes feel free
o'night see one new night see one you
can play I don't know if might see one
does anything though because clean up
six or clean up three talking up six
like b2 and queen take o night B - Wow
you know what happens I think after
night b2 there is light I got six kind
of an intermediate move after take take
take you lose the night
I think yet maybe you guys saw the move
gracefully
the move is like taking four yeah and I
take you for it may not come to mind
right away because it loses your queen
but the idea is you're sacrificing the
queen for just really good piece
placements you get both nights in the
center after Bishop takes you eight
which happened
rook take th rook supports mud on b3
like almost all the white pieces are
pushed back and black still has threats
here and the material loss isn't that
bad either because it's what a rook and
Knight for Queen so so game continues
and I think we'll just kind of play
through the moves and look in awe at the
wave lat managed to convert this
position there were some improvements
along the way but so I messed up
somewhere I took you for overcast cake
da let's play rook a take D it may be
slightly better but the game continued
from here Knight c3 take on us to free
pawn and f5 I like this move it's very
resourceful blocks pieces are relatively
well placed but black wants to improve
the structure and just have a really
nice pawn chain to support the 93-95
something weird happened here last 86 97
or KC a Nike six basically got into
blacks territory but like flat winning
anything after rift e6 nitrate loss for
Bishop and the problem for whites is I
can't really make use of any of the open
files usually when there's a material
and balance like this and you're you
have a queen or you have the you still
have two rooks you want to look for open
lines to control and here light can't
really activate any of the pieces black
has more space and black has control
over so many squares in position and the
Knights do a great job of just simply
defending each other and from maximizing
the number of squares that are
controlled so e4b 394 h5 nice thing for
black like also has time so you can play
moves like h5 and like can't really do
anything in the meantime black is just
perfecting the pieces 95 Queen B -
rookie okay yeah rookie six was the one
that I didn't like from black I don't
think there's any reason to move the
rook off the D file because eventually
black wants to penetrate let's move like
rip d3 so I think a better move here and
just move the King the king h7 I'm kin
the Knights now everything was pretty
perfect and you're ready to fight at e3
next but okay the game still ended
pretty nicely black managed to get in
some moving around this was a blitz game
so a little bit of moving around and now
we can see this position looks really
fun White has no source of counter play
like the Queen would like to comment on
this diagonal but all the squares are
controlled and meanwhile the rook
combined with the two knights are really
good at coordinating especially like
creating mating nuts and I was actually
really surprised because I checked the
engine black doesn't have a fourth mate
here looks like it should be made in a
few more moves but black did play a move
or kind of a sequence which
simplified work h1 I leave it to you
guys black to move inland now you three
this was actually the only winning idea
in this position you could play rook h1
and repeats but 93 was played and like
resigned because the rook on u2 is
pinned to the roof or in by the rook
so the Queen can be too so pretty cool
game any questions I was debating
whether to show the skin I'm going to go
through this game really quickly because
it shows like how a good player beats a
bad player like a kind of beginner and
it was sent to the club by someone who
has never played a rated game in their
life and they sent this game and was
asking I guess me in this case to judge
their ability based on how they played
this game and i will say it's hard to
judge rating based on one game
especially if it's a really short game
and i will say that the player who sends
this game in won this game probably
played like a grandmaster because black
made a bunch of mistakes white did
everything right to take advantage of
those mistakes but I will also say that
it's usually better to look at the games
where you lose because that says more
about your play more about your
weaknesses and you can learn a lot more
from law from those games but for this
we'll just go through very quickly I'll
point out some more basic ideas a black
played normal opening two starts and
then out of nowhere played g5 maybe
inspired by how you found a recent G for
instance but what happened in this game
was black played kind of on the wings
black with slowing developments and
white did everything what rights white
played and center developed the pieces
and then eventually tactics finish
things off so and this is a common rule
which sometimes is overlooked even at
higher levels when your opponent plays
on a flank it is you
the best to respond in the center so
light plays best movie for g4 tick tick
no this is smooth six and black hasn't
developed a single piece still hasn't
and whites being very efficient with
development like every move developing a
new piece improving Queen a4 is nice and
now I'll say that like when your pieces
are on really good squares then you want
to look for tactics and in this position
I'll actually leave it up to you guys
whites to move win material very good
yeah you want to realize that this pin
is very deadly and you want to clear out
the e5 square so this is a classic
clearing static where you remove the
piece from this where you want to access
with the pot and okay one piece was
enough size Queen c2 the finish was nice
to rook do you want during the Queen to
the checkmating square and black
resigned here so any questions about
this ok another really common nice
example of a stronger player beating the
weaker player and I like the way that
White's kind of managed to take away or
take advantage of blacks positional
mistakes and then the game ended really
quickly due to like overwhelming attack
so will see the opening another Kings
Indian this time White is playing and
more mainline and I will say usually in
the King's Indian it is a bit more
common for a black to play e5 here and
if any of you are familiar with the
Kings Indian usually after a five it
might look a little strange because the
pawn is attacked twice only defended
once but this is usually okay for black
because of wife gets greedy tries to
take the pawn after take take let's say
Queens get traded and white captures
upon white is temporarily up upon but
what move can black play in this to the
yeah they taking 4 and this is the power
of your Bishop on g7 and black wings
back upon and probably has a better
position so the mainline Kings Indian
just to show real quickly is like
usually castles black plays Knight c6 d
597 and then it's very sharp game or
light goes for attack on the Queen side
and black goes for some teamfight attack
but this game it was different structure
black played c5 and this is more known
as a vanilla tea structure where if you
ever see black pawn on d5 like pawn or
black pawn on c5 white pawn on d5 you
can instantly think Benoni
and one of the rules about the Benoni is
your Bishop on g7 is your good Bishop
even though the number of your pawns are
in dark squares
the bishop is outside of the pawn chain
so the bishop and the pawns actually
work together to control more dark
squares and this is relevant because
later in the game black made a pretty
big mistake dealing with the bishop
castle a6
another planting Benoni black wants to
play b5 and usually this takes some time
to prepare the black wants to play rook
to b8 sometimes we maneuvered the knight
to c7 and it's very important any
opening play you want to understand what
pawn breaks you want to play in like the
middle game structures so b5 is a pretty
pretty standard plan for black also
standard for white to try and stop me 5
play a4 and here at black played rook b8
which i think is a slight and accuracy
and this is sort of a more high-level
idea but after black plays a6 and white
plays a4 white is actually threatening
to play a5 which should really shut down
the plan of b5 because there would be on
poisson possibilities so the better move
here for black is actually to play b6
and what this does is it attempts to
prevent a5 and then still later allows
black to carry through
with a plan a plan B 5 so this is one of
these ideas which is kind of just unique
to the benoni and if you're an Oni
player you should know about this but
anyway rip the eights light goes ahead
plays a 598 with you two and you go is
this position black made a very very bad
move and sometimes this happens when
you're in a position you don't know what
to do
you might freak out you might just end
up making the wrong decision and really
didn't like blacks move here Bishop
takes c3 and earlier I said the bishop
is one of your best pieces so it goes
without saying that you should not trade
off your your best piece and Maurice
Ashley I don't know if any of you like
watch the US Championship commentary but
he is a very motivated about talking
about trading pieces and he teaches that
you shouldn't trade pieces unless you
have a really good reason for it and
trades should either be forced where you
have to or fantastic where you're
getting something for it in this case
Bishop takes c3 is neither force nor
fantastic so it was pretty bad as we'll
see because after the bishop leaves the
board then the dark words become weak
and the fact that white still has his
own Dartford Bishop creates a lot more
checkmating possibilities so b5 black
finally gets b5 in but it didn't really
end up mattering because after Queen h6
checkmating square is on g7 also h7 and
we'll see after f6 Knight g5 really nice
move taking the advantage of the fact
that this F pawn is pinned to the g7
square and ninety five goes for the
other target on h7 for real kept seven
I think rook F sevens will only moved to
avoid checkmates if I'm not mistaken but
course losses material and then as we
can see black had no chance
this is important too if you're like
attacking and you're of material usually
you don't want to simplify by trading
Queens you want to keep the clean on the
board in this case you keep the Queens
on the board because it's checkmate it's
made into after here and take so pretty
cool game there were few lessons from
this game any questions so far so if I
remember correctly this game was a
really nice attack game for lights and
earlier we saw a game where black made a
very bad positional mistake and that
gave white a really nice attack in this
game we don't necessarily see the same
clear positional mistake we really just
see white building up a nice attack and
then using a lot of initiative and
tactics to his favor now I will say
there were blunders in this game but
we'll get to this so it was a kind of
Sicilian started off as I don't know
what we call this there's so many open
Sicilian variations 96 isn't so popular
most popular variation Sicilian is my
Garf after Knight f6 Knight c3 and a6
one of the issues with 96 at the higher
levels is it allows white to play c4 and
usually if you're playing black in this
position you want to start with Knight
up nice Essex attack the pawn and
provoke white to play Knight c3 but as
we'll see in this game it at left
opening very pretty early flight took
fake Bishop c4 Knight f6 and so you want
to ask you guys a question I asked about
this move e5 so this looks like kind of
an interesting move I don't see if
there's anyone here who would play e5 as
like
if you say yes you should have a reason
that you say no you should have a reason
yeah can I sure use this one castle sure
okay anyone would play so that's true
and when I first saw this position I
thought a five was actually pretty nice
tactical idea and now now we'll get to
that but the idea White's hoping for is
after take you don't take on D it
immediately but you played Bishop take
f7 and then you just win the Queen
rather than just winning the hall that's
okay but the the problem as you point
out with E 5 is Queen a class and this
is a very very common Sicilian tactic
for black where usually early on you
should try and avoid putting stuff on
the fifth rank because whenever they
have cleaning ties check will use a
double attack so I didn't plate you 5
website by T 3 let's get to the more
interesting moment what white did was
expand on the kingside pretty early and
from this moment we know it's going to
be a very sharp attacking game off
subscribe castling white wants to attack
on the Kings side black wants to attack
him Queen side and if we just try and
choose who who would we would rather be
I think most of us would prefer white
white kind of has the jump start on
attacking and white is already ready to
perhaps play g5 or maybe h4 h5 I'll see
like carried through with these plans
pretty nicely so exploring with H 4.95
King be one king d1 is kind of a bend
feingold rule whenever you're Castle
queenside he says always play King d1
and it's one of these typical moves
where the Kings are safer on b1
sometimes you even go to a-1 if there's
pressure on the D file 97
and h5 bishop h7 now we reach a moment
where pretty much every move for the
next four or five moves light misses the
like easy material winning tactic so I
want to give you guys a chance to find
it here white to move when material
yeah 95 and actually when I first saw
this I thought likes to swimming piece
and idea with 95 is after Queen take D -
you don't take back the Queen right away
you take on East Side move check have a
Intermezzo King h8 4 KQ 2 likes just
left a piece now I'm actually realizing
that Queen d8 is possible here but this
would still be good for life because
after take take white wins a d6 pawn and
wipes up a pawn with very very good
position so this tactic whenever the
Queen's are lined up and there's a
knight in the way and blacks King is
castled and there's a piece on e7 which
seems like there's a lot of factors but
this is surprisingly common in a lot of
variations in the Sicilian especially in
these opposite side castle variations
you want to kind of be aware of this
pattern yep
plus the Queen yet always be aware of
the pieces which are on tree not defend
in the position in this case the Queen
on a5 Bishop on e7 even the knight on g7
they're all not defended and that
usually should give you some signal to
look for tactics so okay rook hg1 like
wanting to play g5 what can still play
Knight d5 here it's even stronger
because there's no Queen d8 and like six
winning the bishop but okay a3 was
played Queen e2 here after 95 Queen e2
here a later flight Bishop d2 it takes
time and you're giving black time to
maybe attack you further maybe black has
some idea of eventually four and rook c8
the 95 just means a piece so okay a3
questionable and another common
principle for a position like this is
when there is off like a
opposite side castling you want to try
and shift the focus to the side where
you're attacking so for last several
moves main focus has been on Queen side
which sort of favors black but the good
thing for whites is that black didn't
really ever get anything and g5
eventually comes and we get to this
position where it's pretty uh pretty sad
for black on the Kings side this Bishop
is useless in defending anything and g7
again you see this g7 square is a big
target black had to play g6 there's
probably a few ways to win here like
just takes and don't forget actually
this Bishop can be an attacker because
there is x-ray vision so the c-4 plant
ever goes away on this it could be very
effective
a queen h6 yeah I think Queen Queen f6
and then h6 right can black stop the
mate on g7 I don't see any way to stop
it that looks pretty strong I think
white just wanted to open up the H file
and then a similar idea that you're
checkmating they look helping okay like
just had fun here so many different
mates and final few moves so yeah we saw
some some pretty cool attacking game
okay so this was a game played I even
read the description here I don't know
if the guy says where the game was
played but there are a lot of sacrifices
in this game and a lot of mistakes made
but we'll walk through it we'll try and
at least be entertained white played
probably a not recommend not recommended
version of the French defense may move
here for white is d4
and why sighs Bishop to c4 which is
surprisingly one of the worst moves in
the position hard to think of Orson was
may be keen to or Bishop a6 but Bishop
c4 is not a great move because it's kind
of walking directly into what black
wants to do and well white is trying to
do is fight for d5 but it's actually
making d5 stronger wear a black side d5
anyway and you lose time moving your
bishop twice so after take take it's a
d3 okay I think most of us see the
promise Bishop d2 a flock to D pawn
which blocks a bishop
and this is very kind of painful for me
to look at in in these games where
people put their pieces on squares like
this on v3 normally Bishop d3 is okay at
the pond already on d4 but let's keep
going Knight c3 five a four so White's
breaking decent number of opening
principles actually most of the
principals who move the same piece twice
with both the knight and the bishop and
also moving away from the center black
played well Bishop d6 b3 let's zoom
forward rook e8 92 and oh I think the
guy commented in this position that is
instantly reminded of the bend triangle
rule you never play f3 I think a cost
whitening scheme because f3 even though
it tries to fend off the bishop it's
really weakening to the king side so the
bishop h5 let's zoom forward and this is
really the start of just some very
unexpected moves Bishop hey gage -
probably not a move I would consider
especially given the way that White's
been playing likes been kind of putting
the pieces on unusual squares it
probably makes sense for blacks do
something a bit more sound here and this
complete development maybe play 97 maybe
play c5 but Bishop take H - its
ambitious but it's probably just bad
because you're you're sacrificing
peace and you're not really getting any
immediate play but as we'll see in this
in this game a sort of paid off so can
you take a ch2 Queen b6 black really got
no attack
I'm Bishop take f3 oh this is not a bad
strategy for bughouse or you just sack
pieces hoping you get enough pieces from
your partner to checkmates but in actual
chess when your sacrifice pieces like
this you don't get them back
so I guess what black was hoping for is
to get a mate battle which there is
jerimae threats there is a check on h2
but it was not worth sacrificing two
minor pieces for and white defends 93
now it seems like White's positions
really good given the way he played in
the opening he's up to pieces his
bishops are actually really well placed
he has some open lines to attack with
seems like it should be very much in
white favor and white was better for
next level moves responded to blacks
breaths Knight f1 defending h2 rook h3
very fine rook take aged seven you see
the the bishops and the rook coordinate
very well before fake so how many pieces
of black sacrifice so far the bishop on
each to the other bishop on f3 and now
the pawn on d4 90s six run some slack
the h3 rook take tea for another
sacrifice now I had a friend in high
school like 2100 I don't know how he got
the 2100 but his main philosophy in
chess was sacrifice everything it might
be checkmate and we're going to see this
in in this game just stacking everything
hoping for something good to happen in
95 and see if White has significantly
more pieces what up rook and the bishop
pawns are equal but black pieces are
actually kind of scary-looking
this is a 7 another pawn sacrifice
now 9f2 kind of scary-looking move and I
want to see if anyone can find the right
move here for white because you do have
to be careful and why it was not careful
here so white to move how should you
defend
Queen s3 I think is a very good move
yeah Queen a3 is probably one of the
best moves the move that white played
was king cake up to taking the final
sacrifice piece black had to at least
sacrifice like six pieces and pawns and
then Queen take G to me so we see this I
don't think any of you have seen the
immortal game where there's all these
sacrifices and like checkmates in a very
beautiful manner I'm not sure if I would
consider this game immortal because so
this year a number of blunders but it
was a least very entertaining and maybe
it will be immortal because it will stay
on YouTube forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]